ok tout à l'heure demain c'est le 11
septembre 2004 et on va célébrer le
troisième anniversaire des attentats
contre les états unis
et là je vous propose d'aller à new york
pour mesurer trois ans après l'impact
économique de la tacc terroristes il
reste des traces du 11 septembre
pascal golomer tristan le bras en 25 ans
passés à new york
jen est n'est pas à sa première
recherche d'emploi mais elle n'a jamais
connu pareille galère
licencié en novembre dernier secrétaire
sans qualification très précises elle
subit de plein fouet le marasme
économique dans lequel new york a
replongé après les attentats de
septembre 2001
je n'ai jamais vu ça c'est la première
fois que je connais de telles
difficultés
auparavant entre deux emplois stables dû
trouver du travail auprès d'une agence
d'intérim qu'ils me paient aujourd'hui
ces agences ne veulent pas de moi elles
ne veulent même pas m'accorder un
entretien certes la reprise pointe son
nez mais bien plus timidement que dans
le reste du pays surtout dans le bas de
manhattan là où s'élevaient les tours du
world trade center
plusieurs grands groupes financiers ont
préféré fuir le quartier après les
attentats à coup de subventions
d'exonérations fiscales
les affaires reprennent peu à peu comme
un symbole une nouvelle tour de verre
émergent déjà au dessus du chantier de
ground zero et les commerçants
retrouvent le moral
eric et ses associés avaient décidé
d'ouvrir une pâtisserie française avant
les attentats ne regrette pas
aujourd'hui d'avoir persévéré
ils vont même ouvrir deux autres
boutiques dans le quartier ça c'est sûr
cachés et compagnes et le disent c'est
parfois
mais les gens sont quand même là dans
l'autre il ya 1 2 il ya trois récents
vont vers des nouveaux restaurants donc
ça bouge
une réussite parmi bien d'autres mais
tous ceux qui depuis trois ans font la
promotion du quartier ne veulent surtout
pas encore crier victoire
on n'est pas revenu au niveau d'avant
septembre 2001 parce qu'il ne faut pas
oublier qu'à l'époque on était en plein
boom économique
mais il ya des indices qui montrent tout
ça redémarre
la ville espère que le complexe
immobilier qui sera construit dans les
années qui viennent à l'emplacement de
grandes 0 apportera l'activité dont le
quartier a besoin
encore faudra-t-il trouver preneur pour
les milliers de mètres carrés de bureaux
qui seront mis sur le marché
le pari est loin d'être gagné